دعنا نقول أننا ذهبنا وحصلنا على قهوة
ستخبرني كيف نجحت ، لذا أولاً
أدخل الرسائل وسأدفع لك خمسة
دولارات أو القهوة التي حصلت عليها من
أجلي هذا الصباح ، لذا فقد دفعت للتو ثم
يمكنني إضافة  قم بالتعليق كما تعلم ،
شكرًا جزيلاً ، والآن يتعين علي
المصادقة باستخدام معرف الوجه ، لذا
انقر نقرًا مزدوجًا على هاتفك ، ستستخدم معرف اللمس
للمصادقة ، لذا يجب أن يكون لديك
ذلك بالقرب من الرسائل ، لذا تلقيت للتو
إشعارًا ، لا أضغط على أي شيء  هذا
حساب بالفعل
صحيح وأنت تذهب إلى المحفظة العلوية سترى
بطاقة Apple للدفع النقدي مع
رصيد الأموال التي أرسلناها ولذا يمكنني
استخدامها باستخدام هذا ولكن يمكنني أيضًا
تحويل هذا إلى حسابي المصرفي.
يمكنك فعل ذلك أو يمكنك أيضًا
إرساله إليّ